[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimize sepsis testing with
culture independent diagnostics and i'm
susie valdez of lab roots and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by t2
biosystems to learn more visit them at
t2biosystems.com now we encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
now before we continue i also want to
encourage you to participate in the poll
questions please take a moment to answer
the questions in the display on your
screen
you'll see them this webinar is
educational and this offers
free education credits please visit the
continuing window at the bottom of your
screen to obtain those credits i'd now
like to welcome our speakers dr aparna
ahuja
chief medical officer
at t2 biosystems and dr james snyder
professor of pathology and laboratory
medicine at university of louisville and
medical director of the clinical
microbiology and molecular diagnostics
laboratory at university of louisville
hospital dr denise utweiler geiger at
the clinical transformation she's a
clinical transformation liaison and
clinical chemist at mather hospital and
north well health welcome to all of you
and now i'd like to encourage
our audience members to take our poll
our first poll question is
how would you rate the level of priority
to improve the diagnosis of sepsis at
your institution
please take a minute to answer this
question for us
and our next question is sepsis causing
bacterial
pathogen is most prevalent
at your institution which one please
take a minute and answer
this question as well
and at this time i want to thank you
again for joining us today aparna james
denise welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
i just wanted to confirm whether you
could see the presentation
good morning everyone thanks for
participating in this session i'm really
excited to be discussing this very
important topic
optimizing sepsis testing with culture
independent diagnostics
sepsis is the body's extreme response to
an infection and is a potentially
life-threatening medical emergency
and early treatment improves chances of
survival so on that note we know that
sepsis is a burdensome condition
across the world in terms of morbidity
mortality and health care cost sepsis
represents 62 billion in u.s health care
cost
claims more life each year than three
leading causes of cancer deaths combined
and cdc data states that each year 1.7
million adults in u.s developed sepsis
270 000 americans die as a result of
sepsis
one in three patients who dies in a
hospital have sexes
another concerning fact is that the
hospitalized coverage patient as
compared to hospitalized influenza
patients faces a 22 higher risk of
developing sepsis and is 113 more likely
to experience septic shock
anti-microbial resistance is on the rise
globally and is one of the biggest
public health challenges of our time
cdc reports that each year in the u.s
more than 2.8 million people get an
antibiotic resistant infection and more
than 35 000 die
that means on an average someone in the
us gets an antibiotic resistant
infection every 11 seconds and every 15
minutes
someone dies as a result
antimicrobially resistant infections are
estimated to cause 1.27 million deaths
annually worldwide
and
as
mentioned by
dr tread rose
gabriel says the director general of
world health organization code 19
pandemic has led to an increased use of
antibiotics which ultimately will lead
to higher bacterial resistance rates
that will impact the burden of disease
and deaths during the pandemic and
beyond and we are seeing that happening
as of today
the concern with antimicrobial
resistance is
i mean i would say the multiple concerns
and one fact is that
although it has been proven that
prevention and infection control efforts
can reduce death from antibiotic
antibiotic-resistant infections
the number of people facing antibiotic
resistance is still too high
there's lack of early detection of
pathogen or confirmation of absence of
certain pathogen leads to prolonged
empiric therapy
which also contributes to
the emergence of antimicrobial
resistance over prescribing
antimicrobials leads to emergence and
spread of antimicrobial resistance and
with in this situation where
the early detection is challenging
over prescribing is seen as being
acceptable
antimic antibiotic stewardship plays an
important role in optimizing the use of
antibiotics
as per cdc study is estimated that
nationally more than 4.6 billion
annually is spent to treat infections
caused by six multi-drug resistant germs
frequently found in healthcare
and
um it's very important to know that if
no action is taken the death toll
because of amr could rise to as much as
10 million deaths annually by 2050 and
cause a 3.8 reduction in annual gdp
the challenge of detecting sepsis
causing pathogens is is that
the current standard that is blood
culture is race against time
as time to result is on an average two
days varying between one to five days
thus there's reliance on empiric therapy
which we know is optimal in
about 30 to 60 cases
to mention
certain other challenges the positive
positivity rate with blood culture is
low the contamination rate is high
and
it is also
in the administering antibiotics prior
to culture or
periodical issues like improper specimen
collection can alter the results
based on the impress impressive work
done by kumar at all it we all are very
well aware that each hour of delay
treatment increases mortality risk by
about eight percent during septic shock
i'm sorry
here the data from cdc is shown stating
that more than half of the antibiotic
prescribing for selected events in the
hospital was not consistent with
recommended prescribing practices
and prescribing can be improved through
optimizing antibiotic selection
using the shortest effective duration of
therapy and
reassessing antibiotics and reassessing
antibiotic treatment when diagnostic
testing results are available
soon sooner the diagnostic test result
is available sooner targeted therapy can
be started which can improve hospital
antibiotic usage and helps fight
antibiotic resistance as per cdc
the time to
appropriate therapy is a key driver of
clinical outcomes and the extended time
from presentation to appropriate therapy
remains a major contributor to poor
patient outcomes and proliferation of
antimicrobial resistance
the current standard of care as we
discussed
takes can take up to three days to
provide the results which can delay time
sensitive life-saving targeted tree
treatment
and prolonged use of broad spectrum
antimicrobial is a key risk factor
associated with development and spread
of antimicrobial resistant organisms
also we know that rapid diagnosis and
treatment could prevent
as many as eighty percent of sepsis
death
the left side of the slide
is the time of sample collection
and it takes about one to five days to
get a positive blood culture
there are many culture based rapid
diagnostic tests which can provide
the species id
in one to three hours very quickly
however only after the blood culture
turns positive
these cannot be leveraged until culture
becomes positive and cannot be utilized
in cases of culture negative sepsis
culture negative sepsis is a common
cynical concern
where the patient appears septic with a
lack of pathogen growth on culture
and the non-culture based tests are not
reliant on culture positivity or
influenced by antibiotic intake
prior to the test t2 biosystem
diagnostic panels are the only fee
marked and fda cleared test that
provides species identification and the
only cmark test that detects antibiotic
resistance markers directly from whole
blood
and within three to five hours of the
first draw
this
just
mentions quickly um the differences
between culture-based and culture
independent testing
as we mentioned the culture-based tests
they depend on the blood culture
positive positivity impacted by presence
of antibiotics
main clue resistance marker the examples
are filmmary pcr molecule of nat
phenotypic and generative resistance
markers while culture independent tests
are their usage is
dependent on the patient selection
criteria algorithms provide opportunity
to rapidly escalate the escalate as
there is no dependence on the blood
culture turning positive that time is
is
very valuable resistance marker may not
always be provided certain examples are
next-gen sequencing procalcitonin
anti-t2mr based identification
culture independent tests are
are simple to use and the fda cleared
t2df instrument is a fully automated
walk away clinical multiplex bench top
there are seven individual random access
drawers
which can be loaded at any time no
batching is required
user friendly touchscreen display
provides step by step guidance to the
operator
to load a sample all in 10 minutes or
less
so
i would say in in broadly if this is
very sensitive the limit of detection is
as low as one cfu per ml and the
specificity is is more than 98
on across the panels
talking about the t2 canada panel uh it
covers the five five fungal pathogens
mentioned on this slide and these
pathogens are known to lead to more than
90 of the invasive candidiasis
this is both fda cleared and ce marked
and has high sensitivity as i already
mentioned and specificity of 99.4
percent
the teto bacteria panel is designated is
designed for the detection of most of
the escape pathogens
and which are a group of infectious
bacteria that have garnered particular
attention for the ability to escape or
evade common therapies through
antimicrobial resistance
escape pathogens are resistance against
common empiric therapies
fk pathogens remain a major healthcare
burden
a recent study found that escape
pathogens when compared with non-escape
pathogens were associated with 3.3 day
increase in length of stay
a 55
hundred
dollars increase in cost of care and a
2.1 absolute increase in mortality
the the specificity of this panel is
very high 98 and sensitivity is very
high to 90 percent
uh this is both fda cleared in c marked
and
to note it's very impressive that t2
bacteria panel is the first in vitro
diagnostic test to receive approval from
uscmf for new technology add-on payment
the t2 resistance panel is not fda
cleared it is only free marked currently
and the clinical trial a multi-centered
clinical trial is has been initiated
it's ongoing this year
it it covers 13 molecular markers of
antibiotic resistance
both gram positive and gram negative
and this is currently available in the
us as research used only
while it is available or us's female
product
and it's it is worth mentioning like
other many other
ibd companies t2 also came out with the
t2 stars covered two panels with a very
high ppa and npo of 100
and it detects all variants um of of
transcorporate virus that are known as
of today it is available only in the us
currency
the the workflow
of uh this test you need basically four
ml of the patient blood load it into the
instrument
uh and the ins within the instrument the
cells are lies the target dna is
amplified and the the
nanoparticles are clustered the
clustering is detected as change in t2
relaxation time of hydrogen nuclear in
the sample
this is a proprietary methodology
enabling inhibition free dna
amplification in complex clinical
matrices
and there's no background interference
from either human dna or antibiotics and
the prioritical process is really
simplified by eliminating extraction and
purification of dna
and t2mr enables
measurement directly from blood sample
enabling very high sensitivity
as
it's well known that secondary bacterial
and fungal infections
including the antimicrobial resistant
infections are likely to occur in a
significantly
high proportion of hospitalized patients
with covid i did want to quickly mention
a multi-center retrospective cohort
analysis from 241 acute care hospitals
of
more than 590 000 patients
evaluating covert 19 and secondary
infections
it showed that covet positive patients
were
almost two times as likely to have a
pathogen detected during the hospital
onset period
and
longer
hospital stays and longer icu stays for
patients that tested positive for
sarcoid 2 and secondary infection
pathogen
and if you note if you look at the table
which is on this slide you can see that
the most commonly seen pathogens
secondary pathogens encode patients are
actually covered by the t2 panels
days growing real world evidence
demonstrating positive impact of t2
canada and t2 bacteria on patient care
and antimicrobial stewardship
across hospitals we note reduction in
icu and hospital length of stay faster
initiation of targeted therapy as well
as discontinuation of antimicrobials and
hospital savings
and interest of time i'm not going to
the details but you can see certain
recently
done prospective and retrospective
studies are noted on these slides which
demonstrate this and these are done
these have been done in u.s and out of
usd studies
a meta-analysis of 14 control studies
was published in a peer-reviewed journal
in
in may 20 may 2021
and
it
it demonstrated
that the time to detection as well as
species identification
with t2 t2
versus blood culture was decreased by
three days there was faster time to
targeted antimicrobial therapy for
patients testing
uh positive on t2mr by 42 hours and
faster time during de-escalation from
empirical therapy for patient testing
negative on d2mr by 7 hours
shorter length of icu stay and hospital
stay by 5 days
and this this
shows
the recent clinical data on d2 t2 backed
on
recent clinical data on t2 resistance uh
panel
uh again here what we can
see is that
um this demonstrates higher sensitivity
and specificity faster time to result
escalation and de-escalation of
antibiotics
and these are also recent studies which
have been done or u.s
and i would want to before i hand over
to dr snyder i just wanted to conclude
by saying that rapid diagnosis
diagnostics and sepsis management
is critical for timely initiation of
targeted therapy and currently available
culture independent technologies are
innovative and can improve time to
result and ultimately patient outcomes
blood cultures remain the gold standard
for diagnosing bacterial fungal blood
stream infections but are limited by
slow turnaround time and sensitivity
the limitation of blood culture and the
quality standard for sepsis lead to
uh
lead to aggressive empiric blood broad
spectrum antibiotic therapy and this
practice may result in unnecessary
antimicrobial use toxicity and
antimicrobial resistance
culture independent rifle diagnostic
tests that detect pathogens directly
from blood can transform clinical
practice by decreasing resource
utilization and improving clinical
outcomes
understanding of how to incorporate
these innovative tests into clinical
testing and treatment algorithm are
necessary for successful implementation
and handing over to dr schneider for
discussing more of this thank you
you arparna
and welcome everyone uh we're going to
be talking more about the real world
experiences that we've encountered
since uh
adding this particular technology to our
service
as you know these are my conflict of
interest
about eight years ago we decided that uh
rapid diagnostics would be our primary
driving philosophy
in moving our laboratory forward
into what i call the uh technology era
and uh specifically the cutting edge
technology
so
what what has driven
this concept to
drive our laboratory forward
well obviously it's important that we
should be able to not only accurately
but quickly diagnose
laboratory diagnosis
infectious diseases
obviously
excuse me okay
culture remains is the gold standard of
course but it has low sensitivity
and it also increases our turnaround
time to generate final results
we need to influence through
antimicrobial stewardship
the initiation of appropriate therapy
specifically targeted therapy
in our efforts to reduce
morbidity and mortality
as i said very much a part of the
antimicrobial stewardship program
usually with empiric therapy initiated
maybe stay on for three or four days
with rapid diagnostics such as t2
we've been able to demonstrate that they
get more
targeted therapy
or even discontinue therapy and all that
adds up to money of course of which the
administrators like to see
and we also like to promote
unnecessary use of antibiotics as well
as antifungals
reduce poor outcomes
reduce length of stay
and yes readmission which we define as
30 days after discharge but being
readmitted for
the situation that they were initially
admitted for
and then i emphasize once again to
support the
sepsis program very very important
uh arpana went over the targets that the
bacterial and canada
panels have
uh i will not belabor the point here but
you we have both t2 bacterial and t2
canada
we also have diagnostic stewardship
activity in our institution and
anytime we bring on a new service we try
to
determine what is the optimal use
for this type of technology
so in regards to the t2
the testing is restricted to high-risk
patients and that's based upon the fact
that our epidemiology clearly shows
uh this is where
you're going to find a majority of your
pathogens both
canada as well as the bacterial
so we have identified the intensive care
units the transplant patients both solid
organ
and bone marrow
our oncology patients and the emergency
rooms
so these were our targets to
limit if you will or
to restrict testing to
the areas where you're going to have the
highest return on your investment
also the training of phlebotomists is
very critical and i'll say more about
that in a few moments uh in situations
where nursing is drawing blood cultures
uh they have to be trained and even the
clinician should be aware not
necessarily draw but sometimes the
clinician does have to draw
a blood specimen for culture and maybe
in this case t2
and as mentioned previously the sample
is a three to four mil
separate tube
and i emphasize a peripheral blood only
no line draws
and blood culture
must be collected simultaneously
at the time of the t2
so we collect the blood culture we
collect the t2 at the same time
once again a separate
container for the t2 sample
and then our standard 20 ml blood
volume draw for our blood cultures
aerobic and anaerobic
i should share with you that we started
looking at this over five years ago
and as a result of that we were hindered
quite a bit by the hospital being under
a private management company
who resisted moving forward with
technology such as the t2
because of what they felt were costs
so
we put together a multi-disciplinary
team with the idea that
they could influence
the
acquisition
of the instrument for use in our service
three years
or this say
three years ago the private company was
replaced
by a separate
university-based group so we are a
private individual
account if you will
in which
the team approach has been very
effective
so in our approval process beginning
with verification etc
we did our cost analysis
including our direct costs queer
reportable
we estimated the savings to the
institution based upon antimicrobials
in lincoln stay
and had the cost of one day in the
intensive care unit and the others and
we used those as our financial
foundation
to justify our costs
test verification data was generated
we also provided literature support
uh in terms of
uh
working with the administration
we also had to look at with the impact
on workflow
we were fortunate to be 24 7
dedicated microbiology staff and
workflow has not been a problem
and these tests are done as soon as they
come in i.e stat
around the clock
and then we obtain letters of support
from our major team players
pharmacy
bone marrow pulmonary and so forth and
as a result of that all these added up
to
us being able to present
and acquire
the instrument for
use
so once it was decided that uh the
instrument was approved by the
administration we now needed to
implement it
and it started with the training of the
phlebotomy team of which the company was
very good in terms of their support and
also trained in nursing personnel and i
should
inform you we are
a network-based core laboratory we serve
eight
facilities in our region
four of which are hospitals
and uh once again these people
have been trained we're waiting to train
one more hospital just came aboard in
the last year
but the key was or the goal was is to
promote
uniformity
of the sample collection
the laboratory staff was only
but also of course uh for
round-the-clock coverage we trained four
individuals uh to
run the t2 system
we created an electronic order as well
and in that order we have t2 plus blood
culture the purpose of that was to
remind the ordering physician if you
want a t2 you also have to have a blood
culture
we would not accept a t2 sample
without an accompanying blood culture
we will give them 45 minutes
flexibility from the time the t2 is
collected to the time of the blood
culture but it's a more than 45 minutes
let's say an hour uh the t2 test is
rejected
but once again
it's been a learning environment to say
the least but we are seeing more and
more
our medical staff becoming comfortable
with how to order it and what is needed
we call positive results immediately to
the ordering service
including the
pharmacy and once again we place great
emphasis on the importance of that t2
sample
being accompanied by blood culture
i wanted to put this up here because we
were having problems with blood volume
and you can see in this tube
what we did was fill several tubes with
methylene blue
up to four mls and distributed those to
the respective services
to use as a guide in collecting the
appropriate volume
of blood necessary for the t2
testing
we also require an extra t2 tube to be
collected with
the order to ensure that we have a
backup in the event that there is a
technical problem
or
possibly an under fill
in the original tube so if you order a
t2 canada two tubes
if you order a can or a bacterial panel
two tubes
uh as a result of that it's starting to
to work very well but this is one of the
learning
situations we have because there is
turnover in nursing there is turnover in
phlebotomy
so it's a constant reinforcement
to ensure that the uniformity standard
that we try to set
is maintained
this particular slide gives us a lot of
information because they're
into in balance especially on the t2
canada and each of these categories the
sample check the procedure check and the
interference check is very very
important we have a pathology resident
right now
investigating
a few in invalids that we have
encountered
and looking for whether or not
any of the
substances that you see listed here
are in the
patient's history
and one thing we've noted on a couple
patients was they had an mri with
contrast and of course contrast
can interfere
and give you negative results on the t2
matter of fact the bone marrow people
have this posted up in their unit to
remind their nurses because they draw
all the blood specimens that is the t2s
in this case and the blood culture so
once again the procedure check is very
important that's more
pre-analytical as it replies to the
laboratory in addition to the sample
check so the far right hand column here
the interfering substances check
is very very important for your
providers to be aware of and once again
we reinforce that periodically
so our suggested ordering protocol is is
listed as follows here
oncology and transport or transplant
services we recommend ordering a t2
candidate panel only
because fundemia is very prevalent in
those patient populations
the icu's react we recommend a t2
bacterial panel be ordered the emergency
room
where we
see a lot of our volume we recommend t2
bacteria panel
and then infectious diseases can order
whatever they want
but once again uh if they order both
bacteria and can canada
we have to have
at least two three
to four ml samples but since then we've
added that extra tube on to
ensure that we
end up in the event of an error
technical breakdown or something
the option to order both panels yes they
do have that option
the results uh in three to four ml
samples are accompanied by a 20 ml
peripheral blood culture so a physician
can order both but in our suggested
ordering protocol
we have shared with them this is where
we see the highest return
on our testing
given the type of patient population and
it supports the concept of diagnostic
leadership very well
so that backup specimen we find is very
very helpful it's rare that we have to
use it but we have it there
in the event that we have a problem
and just to show you some data you could
say well we don't have a lot of numbers
well this is a
two months worth of data
and you can see the sensitivity of the
t2 in the bacterial panel is is higher
than that in the blood culture so once
again for the targeted organisms
the t2 panel is very good
and it also has as it will for the
canada panel
a high sensitivity and the other thing
that we looked at was the negative
predicted value and the negative
predictive value is very high so what
does that mean clinically
that simply means that if it's negative
you could possibly stop therapy that's a
clinic
clinician's decision but at the same
time we feel comfortable saying you
might want to consider
terminating therapy and this is where we
work with our pharmacists and the
pharmd's who are on the units that can
influence this
on each of the respective units that
they cover but once again
the canada
and so forth
as you can see here the different
species
we did pick up
uh
through sensitivity on the t2 the canada
albicans tropicalis and parapsilosis
matter of fact we had a perapsilosis
just before we went live this morning
and bone marrow called me and said
should we believe this and i said of
course
and the patient is now on the
appropriate targeted therapy so it gives
you example of the influence and impact
that the laboratory can have
on the
patient management
we also get other positives that are not
in the database and this is some of the
or represents some of the organisms that
we have recovered phenotypically in
blood culture that obviously are not
detected in the t2 so we look at the t2
as a screening
test we also look at it as a supplement
to our phenotypic blood cultures and etc
and this slide clearly points out
the
other organisms as you can see now the
canada species
obviously
was recovered but it was not detected by
the t2 because of the specificity of the
t2 so once again these organisms are not
in the database and as a result of that
it says the t2 will supplement
the blood culture
and phenotypically
it's very very important to realize that
now i will say that physicians continue
to be although they're starting to come
around
and they have been trained this way to
to rely on phenotypic results
so genomic results such as the ct
they're somewhat nervous about it
but as we learn and gain more experience
and share that with them
in our studies they're beginning to
become more comfortable with the t2
results and just like the t2 results
that i shared with you a few moments ago
with the candidate for absolutist that
immediately initiated
targeted therapy for that particular
patient so we will follow up and see how
it came out
will we get t2 negatives and culture
pauses occasionally well this is an
example right here on this slide t2
negative culture positive
and once again
that's why it reinforced the fact we
look at it as a screen
and a supplement
to our standard phenotypic
culture and animal susceptibility as
well as antifungal therapy
when we do our fungal susceptibility
testing
i want to thank sierra spilling one of
our young aggressive
very involved medical technologists who
has put the previous data that i showed
you together and she sent me another
load of data last night of which i've
not had an opportunity to look at
but i'm sure it's going to be very very
informative with regards to
the activities that we're seeing with
our t2
i forgot to mention earlier that in our
justification we also included the cpts
codes that are
assigned to the t2
now granted cpt codes are used for
reimbursement of outpatients in all
these cultures or testing or referring
to here are inpatients which are drg but
we use the cpt codes to
monitor our staffing needs
and
with the reimbursement
from these respective canada and
bacterial panels it adds value to our
staffing
situation
which has been supported greatly by the
data that we present them to show them
our workload but once again there are
cpt codes
we can discuss that later if anybody has
any questions
but
i will now
turn it over to our next speaker and
thank you very much
thank you dr schneider
and let me add my warm welcome to the
attendees and i'm delighted to be with
you to share with you how choosing
wisely drives change to innovative
technology for high value patient
outcomes
shown here are my disclosures
during our brief time together today our
objective is to describe how choosing
wisely
can provide an effective framework for
driving clinical practice change for
those high value patient outcomes
let me tell you a little bit about matha
hospital northwell health
mather is a
248-bed not-for-profit teaching hospital
that was established in 1929 as the
first community hospital in its area
we're located in new york state about 65
miles east of new york city on the north
shore of long island
and masa has what we call many
specialty signature programs which are
continually changing to meet the health
care needs of our community
in 2008 we began our voyage to
excellence initiative with the mission
of being the best community teaching
hospital in new york state
our laboratory is new york state and
joint commission accredited and performs
about 2.4 million tests per year
our hospital has been recognized for
excellence in patient safety
we've also received magnet status from
that institution for nursing excellence
and in december of 2017 nasa became the
proud member of northwell health making
it the largest network within new york
state and in 2021 ascp recognized our
choosing wisely committee as a choosing
wisely
champion
in january of 2016 colleagues from all
areas of our hospital were invited by
the medical board to join our choosing
wisely initiative
the invitation provided background
information regarding the choosing
wisely initiative of the abim foundation
and over 26 sub-specialty societies
each society has published a list of
guidelines that are relative to their
particular sub-specialties in order to
provide guidance to physicians and their
patients about the appropriate use of
tests and procedures
for mather our high level goals for this
multidisciplinary team include review of
evidence-based guidelines to stimulate
discussion about frequently audited
tests and or treatments and to develop
tools to ensure clinicians make
effective care choices
thereby improving quality and enhancing
patient outcomes
while also
optimizing health care resources it was
really here
that we knew the laboratory could be a
critical contributor to this initiative
because we do provide crucial
information to clinicians for improving
prevention diagnosis treatment and
management of the patient
just this year we updated our mission
statement shown here
and it has three main elements the first
to foster evidence-based medical
practices in all possible avenues at
mafa hospital
two to reduce wastage of resources by
advocacy of value-based care in matha
hospital and three
to promote free and open scholarly
discussion on any subjects pertaining to
either of the above aims when necessary
so these really cover all the pillars of
our voyage to excellence
if we look at our choosing wisely
objectives they're simple
we want to have better matching of
patient care to the appropriate level of
patient needs it must also be of high
value with specific attention to the
needs of specific patient populations
and their specific clinical conditions
such as diabetes heart failure sepsis
and renal disease just to mention a few
also by looking at guidelines and
implementing evidence-based medicine we
can change everyday standard practice to
meaningful science that will lead to
more effective patient care treatments
and outcomes
thereby eliminating the overuse of
ineffective care
but i like to say if only changing
clinician behavior was this
easy some of the key performance
indicators of our initiative for
choosing wisely include identifying a
challenging issue
or recognizing an opportunity where we
can improve the process and quality
but most importantly there must be a
patient benefit
the change must improve patient safety
and enhance patient satisfaction
improve patient outcomes by decreasing
length of stay
reducing mortality and significantly
decreasing hospital quiet infection and
readmissions
and additionally we want to avoid
unnecessary tests and treatments while
delivering the appropriate level of care
and optimizing health care costs
some of the key questions to consider
when looking at proposed initiatives
include can patient outcomes and
satisfaction be improved can we
demonstrate measurable
outcomes what are the potential savings
can clinical practice be changed well we
believe the answer to all of these
questions are yes
well it takes a village collaborating
together to make things happen
successfully as dr schneider pointed out
and as you can see from this list that
our committee represents clinical
departments clinicians nursing finance
and the c-suite making it truly a
multi-disciplinary committee
shown here and on the next slide are
some of the initiatives that we've
encountered over the last five years and
these initiatives
are in the diagnostic testing space of
not only the laboratory but also imaging
so now let's turn our attention and
looking at how leveraging innovative
technology
like t2 can assist us in the battle
against sepsis and support our
initiatives for our sepsis task force
you've already heard about the bad boys
the escape pathogens shown here are five
of the deadly bacterial pathogens that
are associated with over 90 percent of
sepsis cases as well as these ones as
present possessing multi-drug resistant
properties together they're collectively
known as the escape pathogens you've
already heard they cause over 2 million
illnesses and over 23 000 deaths per
year according to cdc
we know that they're also the leading
cause of hospital acquired infection an
infection with one of these pathogens in
the bloodstream is associated with
increased mortality and death
so for our committee the first data
analytic metric that we wanted to look
at was who is our key stakeholder who
could we identify as our champion
partner based on the frequency of blood
cultures ordered and you can see here
very quickly on the graph the standout
order number one ordering department is
the emergency department the ed
represents 70 of the orders followed by
internal medicine at almost 18 percent
[Music]
based on the fact that the ed was our
number one blood culture user we wanted
to take a deeper analytical dive and
look at some data metrics regarding
positive blood cultures and what
pathogens were identified in a six-month
period and that period of time was from
january 2021 to
june 2021
the results were that
there was a total
one
of
and three blood cultures ordered by the
ed
and of those four thousand one hundred
and three blood cultures
248 blood cultures were positive for a
pathogen
during the this six-month time period
the blood culture contamination rate was
1.75
or represented four blood cultures
leaving us with 244
positive blood cultures
of these 244 positive blood cultures we
wanted to see how many of these positive
blood cultures could have detected
a bacterial organism using the t2
bacterial panel
a review of the data reviewed that 142
blood cultures could have been
identified as having a
pathogen on the t2 panel
so our analysis further revealed that 58
of the total positive blood cultures
could have been rapidly identified
with one of the five sepsis causing
pathogens using the t2
bacterial panel with a single blood
tube collection
also the t2 results would have been
available to college clinician at least
24 hours earlier
than the traditional blood culture
results
and there would not be any interference
from antibiotics on board the patient at
the time of drawer
and third we could initiate targeted
antibiotic treatment at least 24 hours
sooner which can lead to high value
patient outcomes
i know this was one of the poll
questions in the beginning
asking you if you know what is the most
common pathogen in your organization and
i have to tell you that before this
retrospective review
it was not really clear as to which
pathogens we were actually seeing and
you can see here that um the breakdown
of those 142 ed positive blood cultures
it actually represented 88 unique
patients and our number one pathogen was
e coli followed by staph aureus in mrsa
followed by
klebsiella pneumoniae pseudomonas
originosa
and no one really thought that we saw
much enterococcus fascium but we
actually had two patients so it really
brought to the surface what we were
seeing in our specific patient
population
so my question to you is
who wouldn't want to know if a patient
has an escape pathogen in three to five
hours with a single blood drawer
if we look at performance
characteristics for the gold standard
which has traditionally been the blood
culture and compared to magnetic
resonance technology you can see that
the magnetic resonance technology with a
sensitivity of 90 percent in specificity
of 98
outperforms the traditional blood
culture
the sensitivity of blood culture is
overall low at 50 percent and that's
partly because blood culture depends on
the blood volume drawn
the timing of the blood drawer whether
the patient has had any prior treatment
with antibiotics as well as the presence
of a viable organism
additionally contamination results
are responsible for more than 1.4
million patients per year having full
positive blood culture results and this
leads to misdiagnosis which then can
lead to unnecessary antibiotic treatment
extended hospital stays and increased
mortality and cost
the value of the t2
i'm sorry
shown here is the recommendations from
our choosing wisely committee
and we chose to target high-risk
patients who are presenting to the
emergency room so to start off our
journey at our institution ed clinicians
may order a t2 bacterial panel for
patients who are presenting with
clinical signs and symptoms of blood
stream infection and or sepsis or at
risk of progression to sepsis
and starting empiric therapy
that also must be followed up by
infectious disease consultation
so we believe that the value of the t2
bacterial panel is unquestionable and
that it saves lives and dollars
if we look at the cost of 140
to the laboratory the value that we
receive back is that we have rapid
direct genus and species identification
with no antibiotic interference in less
than three to five hours with a single
blood drawer
as you heard from dr
schneider this also promotes antibiotic
stewardship
it then allows for de-escalation of
antibiotics by the pharmd in
consultation with clinicians
and it enhances patient care management
by changing broad spectrum antibiotics
to targeted antibiotic therapy thereby
improving patient outcomes and providing
high value outcomes for our patients
well what lessons have we learned well
there are many and there's even been
some bumps along the way but first it's
paramount to continue to have assessment
of all of our initiatives otherwise
progress and performance can drop off
significantly it's also important to
keep lines of communication open which
is critical between all stakeholders
we also have found that data analytics
play an essential role in everything we
do
and additionally that information
technology can assist with hard wiring
of changes for sustained use and
successful metrics
we also realize that change is slower
than expected especially in a covered
world today
and it's important to have patience and
recognize and celebrate the winds
as i said collaboration among all
stakeholders of paramount for success
and understanding everyone's strengths
and weaknesses is also important
who better knows the strengths and
weaknesses of our tests than you the
laboratorian so it's an opportunity for
us to step up bring value and provide
education information and guidance to
clinicians for enhanced clinical
effectiveness
thereby allowing us as laboratorians to
be part of the integrated healthcare
delivery team
and finally be prepared to make the
journey and shift from volume to more of
a focus on value
and finally remember there has to be
something for everyone among all the
stakeholders and especially for our
patients
with that i'd like to conclude with
choosing wisely can provide an essential
and strategic framework for implementing
t2 testing panels an implementation of
t2 can demonstrate how the laboratory
can directly contribute to enhanced
patient care and outcomes by
implementing advanced innovative
technology
and with that i'd like to thank you and
turn it over to our moderator
well thank you aparna and james and
denise for that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
audience members please ask now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question is for you dr
schneider
are the blood culture instruments
located at each hospital or only at ul
each
each institution has their own blood
culture instrument however we're trying
to standardize that where we use
and select one instrument only currently
we're diverse
and that's a direct result of the
transition we're undergoing right now
but what they will do is send the
positive blood cultures to us
for full workup i also ask them to make
a gram stain and send an unstained
smear
to the laboratory so we can validate or
verify what they initially reported on
site
thank you so much and doctor
what is the change in sensitivity with
lower draw volume of let's say two
milliliters versus the three or four
that's recommended
this is a great question and a very
practical
uh i would say challenge which can be
faced by that
so uh the good news is that the test
actually utilizes and processes 2 ml of
blood
and so if the volume is up to 2 ml
there's no impact on sensitivity we have
data to
show that
so
i hope that answered the question
thank you so much and
dr
weiler-geiger
i've got a question for you as well
our next question
why did you focus on collecting data
from the ed
well we found that the emergency room
was our number one order of blood
cultures and thought that having rapid
accurate diagnosis of sepsis
for the emergency room would be most
important
eighty percent of our admissions occur
from the emergency room um and we
thought that was a good start point in
our specific patient population
thank you so much
and i actually have another question for
you as well
um
how does t2
meet your choosing wisely guidelines
well i think that when you look at
choosing wisely and wanting to bring
high-valued patient outcomes
and to a specific patient population
and given sepsis as a specific patient
population that's associated with high
mortality
it definitely met the criteria for
wanting to bring and leverage innovative
technology for that rapid and direct
diet
detection of genius one speech all
patients
thank you so much
and this next question i have is for dr
snyder
dr snyder
how has t2 affected your lab workflow
excuse me i'll get it
i apologize for the interruption how has
it the t2 affected our laboratory
workflow well we have it in the
molecular
uh laboratory
and
the staff there
around the clock
to our
initially we had to find out how many
people do we need to cover the 24 7.
once we did that
the workflow has not really been a
problem because they know
that when it comes in it's a stat test
and they
process it immediately
and so overall it's not been a problem
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in and remind you that
any questions not answered will be
answered via email today we have time
for one more question what is the
footprint of the analytical instrument
and does it require any
special additions to the room where it
operates such as shielding also an
approximate cost
thank you
for that question
um
so the instrument the footprint i would
say of d2dx the width is 102.9
centimeter
the depth is 62.2 centimeter and uh the
height is 72.4 centimeter
um
the room where it's placed typically the
hospitals and i'm sure dr smile and dr
geiger could add to it
the labs typically have it either in the
molecular
lab or the microbiology lab and we do
not recommend any shielding or anything
in special specific however it needs to
be away from the hvac ducts direct
sunlight
and water sources or culture bench
benches
and the room temperature should be 20 to
25 degree centigrade and humidity 85 or
less that's the requirement
and the other question was about the
cost and i think that's something that
none of the lab people should lab
leaders or
clinicians should worry about because
that that's a discussion you can do with
the
the company t2 by assistance and our
team can address that i i would say
steer away from mentioning the cost
because
that that should not be the concern
about what is the cost of the instrument
it's it's i can just say that it's
the cost is not enough for for anyone to
have a concern
and leave it at that
dr duja and dr schneider and dr
geiger i want to thank you for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i also want to thank
lab roots and our sponsor t2 biosystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
and for joining us today questions we
did not have time to to answer today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand labrets
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone bye
you